the stargate franchise spans three
decades
three tv shows and three movies plus
other non-canon material
want to know where to start we've got
you covered this is the correct order in
which to watch the stargate franchise
any stargate watch through should
logically begin with the 1994 movie
it's the film that launched the entire
franchise and it's the first time
audiences were introduced to the
stargate universe
the plot builds on the popular
conspiracy that aliens built the
pyramids in giza egypt and proceeds to
create a mythology around the wide
ranging implications of that central
concept
played by james spader the main
protagonist of the original movie is an
archaeologist named daniel jackson
he is a confirmed believer in the theory
that aliens built the massive ancient
structures
not surprisingly academia at large
rejects and ostracizes daniel
but as it always tends to be with
crackpot academics and movies
jackson is more correct than he could
possibly know
the us military has managed to get their
hands on an alien device
buried in the sands of egypt which is
dubbed the stargate
eventually jackson teams up with colonel
jack o'neill played perfectly
stoically by kurt russell together they
work to uncover the secrets of the
stargate
as it turns out this large ring-like
device is basically a universal phone
you dial a set of coordinates in 3d
space and if there's a connection
you can transport yourself to another
planet unfortunately for jackson o'neil
and their team this is no vacation on
this new world they quickly become
embroiled in an age-old conflict they
must defeat an evil
alien dictator that calls himself ra
before they can return home to earth
after finishing the movie you get to
enjoy a long uninterrupted stretch of
television in the form of stargate sg1
the series spans 10 seasons overall but
for now we're just going to focus on the
first seven
sg1 is a spin-off from the original film
and picks up roughly one year after the
events of the movie
in the pilot the stargate device
activates on its own and aliens walk
through
killing and kidnapping several us
military personnel
naturally the government reacts by
setting up a secret base called stargate
command to monitor the device
and mount a rescue mission the base is
led by general hammond played by the
always
authoritative don davis who pulls jack
o'neill now played by richard dean
anderson out of retirement
from there o'neil makes contact with and
once again recruits daniel jackson
played by michael shanks
he completes his team with the very
capable samantha carter as played by
amanda tapping and
ultimately the renegade goaled warrior
tilk as depicted by christopher judge
the show quickly establishes that the
gowald are an aggressive highly advanced
alien civilization who are bent on
destroying
and enslaving humanity to protect earth
stargate command
assembles a group of teams led by sg-1
to travel through the stargate exploring
the universe and searching for allies in
the battle against their new foe
each episode has sg-1 visiting new
locations looking for partners and
technology that will give them the edge
over the gowald
but interesting story lines develop as
the show progresses
in the first seven seasons the
four-person team of sg-1
operates out of a secret base in
colorado traveling to other planets and
facing down
all manner of alien threats after
wrapping up season 7 things start to get
a little more complicated
while stargate sg-1 was still in
production mgm took advantage of its
popularity and launched a spin-off tv
series called stargate atlantis
both of the shows took place in the same
fictional universe and their stories run
in parallel to each other
the good news is that sg-1 and atlantis
are mostly independent from each other
they take place in different galaxies
and have entirely different storylines
and casts
but there are a few episodes where the
shows reference each other in some way
you won't have to weave the episodes
together but it's probably best to start
watching stargate sg1 season 8
and stargate atlantis season 1 at the
same time
the climax of stargate sg1 season 7
introduces the lost city of atlantis
the sg-1 team discovers its location
lost in deep space
stargate command sends a permanent team
there which sets up a base and lives as
a colony in the lost city
stargate sg1 season 8 continues the
storyline and by the season finale the
team finally defeats its two biggest
opponents
the gwald and the replicators meanwhile
stargate atlantis introduces several new
characters as well as the team's own
powerful enemy
the wraith continuing on with the trend
your next step should be to watch
stargate sg-1 season 9 along with
stargate atlantis season 2.
once again you don't need to go back and
forth between the two shows but it will
help to watch them back to back since
the events that occur in them
take place at the same time with many
long running series established
characters enter and leave depending on
off-screen events and season 9 was a
massive change for sg-1
both jack o'neill and general hammond
transition into supporting characters
who play minor roles in the series
they are replaced by beau bridges hank
landry new commander of stargate command
and ben browder as cameron mitchell the
new leader of a fractured sg-1 team
additionally vala mao duran a recurring
character played by claudia black
becomes a primary member of the sg-1
team
mal duran is an extremely clever though
morally dubious human alien with a deep
infatuation with daniel jackson
ladies first well then after you
season nine also introduces a new race
of villains known as the ori
these aliens discover the existence of
humans living in the milky way galaxy
and they begin a violent crusade
in our region of the universe the oris
ultimate goal is to convert everyone to
their religion
origen their highly advanced technology
forces sg1 and stargate command to
devise new
and innovative ways to defeat this
menacing foe
meanwhile on atlantis the team there
tries to develop a retrovirus that will
turn the wraith
into humans but the experiments aren't
without flaws with test subjects
producing ambiguous results at best
the wraith who feed on humans discover
earth's location and decide to head
there to use the population as a new
feeding ground
season 10 is the last hurrah for
stargate sg1 and the last time you'll
watch two shows at the same time
being the last season of the series
you'll get to see several major plot
lines wrapped up in sg-1
without giving anything major away the
series finale ties up several threads
including the fate of at least one fan
favorite couple and the climax of the
battle against one of the show's big
bads
after dozens of episodes the final
curtain closes on stargate sg-1 so it's
time to head over to stargate atlantis
season 3.
in atlantis the team manages to prevent
the wraith from assaulting earth but
they fail in their attempts to develop a
retrovirus to defeat their foe
the team on atlantis continue to battle
the wraith even as a new foe is
introduced in the form of
self-replicating nanobots that call
themselves the assurance
these creatures threaten to destroy
atlantis so the team fires up the city's
hyperdrives and heads to the stars
you heard that right the entire city is
a massive spaceship
soon after atlantis flees it's badly
damaged and the crew find themselves
adrift in space
before moving on to the next season of
stargate atlantis you should take a
couple of hours to watch the direct to
video movie stargate arc of truth which
picks up right after the end of stargate
sg1
arc of truth wraps up some dangling
threads about the ori left at the end of
sg-1
and effectively eliminates the enemy
once and for all the movie opens by
explaining the existence of an ancient
object known as the ark of truth a
mysterious machine which has the
capabilities of defeating the aurai
naturally the team is eager to find it
unfortunately for sg-1 it's located on
the oris homeworld
despite it being a suicide mission they
visit the planet and retrieve the device
but in the process
resurrect an old enemy the replicators
the ori gather their forces for a final
assault on our galaxy but
sg-1 activates the arc of truth and
defeats the ori albeit in
an unexpected way see the device reveals
to the priors that the ori are not
gods the priors are humans who serve the
ori and promote their religion
which includes plans to invade earth the
ark of truth causes
all priors to become aware of the true
nature of the ori
and they leave their religion and
abandon the aura altogether
the movie ends with sg-1 preparing to go
through the stargate on a new mission
implying that the story will go on with
the arc of truth wrapped up head back to
stargate atlantis and watch season 4.
there was some transition in the
stargate franchise at this point
for one this is the first time atlantis
aired as the only stargate show on tv
secondly the main cast shifted quite a
bit elizabeth weir played by tory
higginson became incapacitated which
made room for samantha carter to become
a main character in the series
carter made the move from the sg-1 team
and became a series regular on atlantis
thanks for saving our assets back there
from the bad guys
it's a risky move nothing compared to
the risk that you and your team took
the show's tone also took a darker turn
this season season four opens with
atlantis still adrift in space
and the team desperately trying to make
repairs they continue their two-front
war against both the wraiths and the
assurance and part way through the
season make the brilliant move of
pitting both enemies against each other
the atlantis team managed to reprogram
the assurance convincing them that the
wraiths are their enemies and by the end
of the season the wraiths are nearly
wiped out
with only one season of stargate
atlantis remaining it's time to take
another break to watch the next
standalone movie in the stargate
sg-1 storyline stargate continuum occurs
between seasons 4
and 5 of atlantis and completes the
story arc of several characters from sg1
it revolves around one of the only
survivors of the gua wold after their
defeat at the hands of stargate command
ball the last of the guald system lord
survives the destruction of his people
he continued to play a minor role in
sg-1 during seasons 9-10 and
occasionally joined forces with stargate
command but ultimately remains a
villainous figure
in stargate continuum the sg-1 team
finally corners ball
and plans to put a permanent end to him
however it turns out that this is merely
a clone of
ball and the real system lord has
enacted one last plan to gain universal
power
ball time travels to 1939 and actually
prevents the stargate program on earth
from ever happening
doing so creates an alternate timeline
where ball conquers the universe
as he readies an assault on earth a few
members of sg-1 remember the original
timeline
through their efforts they revert
history back to its original course
the movie ends how it started with ball
about to be executed
this time the characters are unaware of
the previous events or an alternate
timeline they complete the extraction
process which brings an end to the guald
for good
it's time to head back to atlantis one
more time the fifth season of stargate
atlantis
is the last fortunately the show does a
pretty good job of wrapping up a bunch
of plot lines
mckay the snobbish geek finally falls in
love with keller the team defeats their
arch enemy the wraith
in the end humans can finally form a
government in the pegasus galaxy free
from the tyranny of enemy alien forces
the series finale of stargate atlantis
is pretty spectacular
the wraith discover the location of
earth and head straight for it dinner
being the only thing on their minds
in response the atlantis team decides to
fly the city to earth and join in a
massive fight to fend off the wraith
after an epic battle and glorious
victory atlantis lands in the pacific
ocean not far from san francisco
the stargate franchise continued after
the end of atlantis in the show stargate
universe
though this latest entry in the
franchise only lasted two seasons
because it was the last of the series
you can watch both in order without
having to split your attention with
other shows and movies
the plot and characters are far removed
from the rest of the franchise which
makes the show
its own independent story arc in
stargate universe humanity discovers an
alien race called the ancients
the ancients sent a ship deep into the
unexplored parts of the universe
the vessel traveled so far that it's
actually almost impossible to get to it
using a stargate
and because the journey is so long it's
basically a one-way trip
the ship doesn't have enough juice to
send the travelers back
a team from stargate command decides to
take the plunge and they wind up stuck
on the ancients vessel the show balances
several storylines including trying to
find a way to get home
surviving this strange new place and
trying to figure out what the ancients
wanted to accomplish with the ship
it turns out the craft was investigating
something incredibly close to the point
in the universe where the big bang
occurred and there's evidence that
life might have existed before the
beginning of the known universe
up to this point we've been going in
pretty much chronological order through
the stargate franchise
the last entry in the list is the
exception stargate origins
is actually a web series that serves as
a prequel of sorts to everything you've
watched so far
the series is set in 1939 long before
the events of the first movie
origins is quite different from the rest
of the shows
it only contains 10 episodes and each is
only 10 minutes long
after the initial release every episode
was compiled into a single movie which
is now available to stream
if you've been binging all of the shows
up to this point you should have no
problem knocking stargate origins out
quickly
the plot follows catherine langford
played by ellie gaul
who is trying to unlock the secrets of
the stargate
in sg-1 langford is a minor character
and a good friend of daniel jackson
it's explained throughout the series
that langford was key in helping to
establish the stargate program
now we get to see more details about her
story in stargate origins
the main antagonist for this short
series is a nazi who surprise surprise
knows about the stargate and how it
works
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you